let's go outside of the tech world so uh
two brands that that I uh I'm looking at
that have lasted a long time Louis
Vuitton Louis Vuitton has lasted maybe
250 years now and when you think of
Louis Vuitton you know what you're
getting same at New York Times New York
Times has been around for 250 years not
Everyone likes them but you know what
they're pursuing which is their version
of the truth but then let's go to
Raising Cane's you ever been to Raising
Canes Dude Love raising case I met the
founder of Raising Canes once he is
awesome
[Music]
we're live what's going on what up how
are you uh I'm thriving all right good
so I've been thinking about this
conversation you and I had we talked
about Outsourcing and I'm actually going
to put a lot of words in your mouth you
didn't actually say everything
I I'm implying that you said a lot of
stuff which you didn't exactly say so so
you're kind of more of a representation
but Rob Dyrdek said something amazing on
this pot uh a few pods ago he said two
amazing things one he goes if I just do
these he goes I was what did he say he
goes I was making I was looking for
these 20 30 million dollar wins instead
I'm gonna look at and I would do like 12
of them he said he goes instead I'm
actually only gonna do one or two things
and I'm and I'm gonna hope that they're
gonna be big and then he also said he
has this thing called Forever Estates do
you remember what he talked about
forever Estates so afterwards he sent me
mock-ups of this and I like Google the
architect and everything and there was
this really cool article that they rob
and the architect wrote together so
forever Estates Rob said I want to build
this home so basically he said he had 12
million dollars liquid at the time 10
million dollars he went and bought this
plot of land
and then he goes to build the home I
want it's going to cost 30 million
dollars at the time I didn't have that
and I it sounds like he maybe he has it
now but he was like basically I want to
build this home where the deer dick
family for many generations can meet at
this home to discuss Family Planning and
family issues and things like that and
so I'm going to build this home exactly
how I want it and we're going to call it
forever Estates because hopefully it
lives forever I found that very
inspiring did you find that inspiring
loved it loved it I love when people
take an absurdly Long View
and more than anything I love when
people have a vision for their life and
what they're doing when somebody's got
it it was awesome and compelling vision
for their life that is like one of the
most attractive traits to me it doesn't
even matter if I agree with that Vision
it's that they have that vision and that
they agree with that vision is what
matters
I thought it was awesome and he sent me
mock-ups of the home and I was like dude
this is so inspiring and so I got I got
all up hot and bothered about this it
was awesome to me and so I started
thinking about companies that can last a
long time uh I've been a little bit
obsessed with this because with Hampton
things are going well we're not a
success yet but it's very clear that
like I always tell our team physics will
allow this to work there's demand I've
got a good audience for this we've got a
good team physics allows us to exist
there's nothing that gets in the way of
this we're already somewhat successful
the only question is how great will it
become and I'm starting to think how do
you create something that lasts 50 in a
or 100 years whatever it is and the word
brand is something that I've been
thinking about a lot and I think you and
I as well as our audience we get in
these like short-term
thinking and we use like the a word the
Arbitrage word or we use like we use
these certain words that people actually
don't think about branding they don't
think about soul and I've been thinking
a lot about that lately and there's this
book that I'm uh reading where it's
called lessons from the century or
lessons from the century companies Club
so it's like this one woman studied like
companies that have lasted 100 years and
she's like what do they all have in
common and I've been thinking a lot
about that and you brought up something
you said you invested in this company
Shepherd which I think is awesome I
actually am starting to use them
um I'll give you a plug is it grow
Shepherd or support shepherdsheper.com
yeah support shepherd.com you talked
about that investment uh in the company
and it's and you're talking about
Outsourcing it's basically you hire
people in the Philippines I think also
Latin America and they do a bunch of odd
jobs but you said something like I want
to hire tons of these people and I
started thinking about that I started
thinking should I do that and then I
realized I shouldn't do that
because I actually should do that for
some roles but the thing that like you
should do it for some rules but I had
this like off-site this like uh Hampton
retreat with like a bunch of our
employees and I realized you have to
build a real strong company culture and
you have to figure out how do you keep
employees for a long time and that's one
of the key keys to building a brand that
can last a long time and I wanted to
hear
how are you and this by the way this
topic is not that exciting for anyone
who's in survival mode this topic is
more exciting for people who are in like
Thrive mode where it's like I got this
thing working to be clear the first
phase of the company is just build
something that people want and figure
out if you can get it to them
um right don't worry about culture don't
worry about brand don't worry about the
forever plan don't worry about the
25-year Vision
um none of it's gonna matter if you
can't do the first thing Sam has done
the first thing with Hampton he has
proven that he can create something that
people actually want and he could sell
it to them so now he's thinking you know
and now you get what I call Progressive
ambition I want to do a whole video on
Progressive ambition I'm going to show
people
if you go back and you watch Mark
Zuckerberg's early interviews and people
are like where does this go from here
you're on eight campuses now you're
where are you gonna we're gonna open
this up to everybody high schoolers
everything he goes he's like 50 schools
he's like well you know our goal is to
get to you know all the major colleges
um I'm not sure everyone keeps saying
why you know expand expand expand some
things are cooler when you don't expand
and I don't think why do we have to open
up to everybody I'm not sure I mean some
some things are really we can build
something really really useful for
college students so maybe we should just
do that
and then now the guy's like
created like hot air balloons that give
internet to Farmers in India so that
they can use Facebook right it's like he
got progressively more ambitious as he
went along and that's which is a crazy
story in itself by the way Facebook uh I
think Sarah helped to work on this or
something at Facebook Facebook basically
puts these planes over India so any
Indian can access Internet because the
issue with growth of Facebook is they
literally have everyone on the internet
they have to create more internet for
people they got to create a bit more Tam
I'm like we're tamping it up right now
hold on we gotta give more people the
internet so they could use our app but
that's cool that it started where that's
a great phrase Progressive ambition very
common for different companies you can
go back I'm a forensic I'm an
archaeologist I go back into the to go
study the early origins of these
companies and you find this very very
commonly that they start with a sort of
humble ambition then as things start to
work they snowball their ambition they
become more and more ambitious as they
go realizing the opportunity is wider
and bigger than they had initially uh
you know planned for and that one step
of success earns the right to go for the
next step of success and that it is okay
to ladder up because what most people do
is they look at them today they say
well now they're trying to do a b c and
d so I when I start need to also plan
for a b c and d and it's actually like
no you actually just start with a you
don't actually have to do anything else
of course there are exceptions there's
Elon Musk saying we're gonna you know
but you know even Elon for example let's
take one of the most ambitious companies
in the world SpaceX right what's the
goal what's the mission statement it's
like make the human species
multi-planetary so we can survive when
we ruin Earth uh or Earth gets you know
hit by an asteroid or whatever and so
it's like wow what's more ambitious than
creating a rock literally rocket science
to create rockets that will eventually
take us to live on Mars wow that's like
the biggest Vision ever
when SpaceX started his initial vision
was to do a test demonstration sending a
plant in a rocket into a certain like a
certain height I don't remember exactly
where it was to you know have the first
living thing you know go out of uh you
know past the moon or whatever wherever
you're trying to take it and that's all
we want to do is just take a plant out
there and he's like oh I'll just fund
this you know take me 20 million dollars
but it'll inspire people towards science
and you know hopefully NASA will then
fund real Mars missions after that and
then only you know along the way he's
like you know what screw this plant
thing I'm gonna let's actually do it
ourselves we don't need to inspire an
asset let's just do the whole thing
ourselves he also got progressively more
ambitious
and also when he first started he
started a thing called zip2 which I'm
almost certain it's basically like
putting the yellow pages on the internet
which I'm sure he had some cute way of
spinning it where it was a grand plan
but it it he made 20 million dollars off
of it which is a lot of money but he was
like in his head he's like I gotta get
my nut you know what I'm saying he's
like you see every every human has a
number a phone number and you can reach
them this is one of the most marvelous
things in the world and you need a way
to reach them it's information you know
he'll make anything sound fancy but
actually one of the interesting things
is Elon is also credited as like you
know the you know he found he created
PayPal he didn't actually create PayPal
uh you know PayPal the product was
created by you know first Max leban and
Peter Thiel but even then when they
merged with elon's company he had this
big vision for x.com he's like x.com is
going to be everybody's full Financial
life it's going to be banking it's going
to be mortgages it's going to be loans
it's going to be sending money it's
going to be savings accounts it's going
to be all things to all people and that
was the vision for x.com when they
merged Elon was the CEO of the merged
company and the plan was to createx.com
and so he had this big audacious crazy
vision
his forever plan about how he's just
going to change the whole financial
system
and actually the only thing that worked
was going back to the basics let's make
something that people actually want see
if we can get it to them and it was like
oh yeah eBay sellers would love a way
for people to to pay the money when they
send them the like beanie babies and so
literally it was send money via send
money via email small amounts
hang a pal was the was the actual use
case that people wanted and needed and
it was only when they essentially booted
him out and focused on that small use
case the smaller Vision did PayPal
actually take off and so you know
sometimes you almost have the reverse or
you start to audacious and actually you
needed you you skipped the step of
finding that initial foothold and that's
what PayPal actually did and here's the
rub which is which is very similar to
that that I'm experiencing that I'm
trying to think about which is how do
you balance
take so so in order to build a company
that lasts a long time you need to you
need a few things which I can talk about
but you it starts with having a brand it
starts with having a very clear defined
purpose it starts with having you have
to have employees who you want to work
with for a long time and there's a bunch
of things but how do you balance paying
the bills and taking customers and also
like having this mission that might be
polarizing to people and I'm trying to
figure out when is that transition do
you always have it and that's something
that I'm that I'm constantly thinking
about now which is like where I don't
think it's a switch I think you have to
have it embedded in your culture early
on
but where do you make sacrifices where
do you make sacrifices I'm not sure I'm
not sure on on going from short term to
long term thinking how that happens and
that's something that I've been thinking
a lot about lately so it's hard to kind
of give advice without any specifics but
I'll
do it anyways I'll be the advice guy for
a second so when I was doing my very
first company it was a stupid company
we're trying to do the I'm trying to
make a restaurant chain the Chipotle of
sushi
and we had all these micro decisions to
make like any business does on a
day-to-day basis should we use this
packaging or this packaging for our
thing well this one costs costs more and
looks better but this other one you know
we would have better margins because it
costs less and then there's this other
one that's eco-friendly and blah blah
and so one of our mentors at Duke she um
sat us down and she's like guys
you're having The Wrong conversation and
we're like what do you mean and she's
like it's not about packaging what do
you mean she's like well let me ask you
this what decision would what decision
can you make Upstream of this that would
make your packaging decision obvious I
was like well we don't really get it
she's like you got to know what do you
value right are you about ruthless
efficiency and margins because if so
then the choice is obvious there's no
choice right you just choose the one
with the cheap packaging with the best
margins are you about
are you is your number one value the
quality of the customer experience
uh because if it's the quality of the
customer experience you're definitely
not going to choose a cheap one but you
also won't choose the Eco one that's
going to kind of melt you know the old
paper straws problem it's not actually
the best product but it is eco-friendly
it's like so if you're all about product
quality that's what you're gonna gonna
go all in on that's your number one
value then the packaging decision is
obvious same thing with the other side
if you're all about sustainability if
that's your number one value then the
decision is obvious she's like you don't
know which packaging to pick because you
don't know what you stand for you don't
know your values and she's like what you
want to do is figure out your values
number one so what are the things you
value more than more than other things
because they're and you only know what
you value when you're choosing amongst
good options it's obvious to Value
something when you have a good option
and a bad option there's no you didn't
test your values there your values only
get tested when you have multiple good
options but they're good in different
ways and that's when you need to know
which one do we value
um the second thing that she said was
uh Jeff Bezos has this great quote where
he goes they're like oh you know Amazon
has been around forever and uh you guys
have just kept growing and growing and
growing and you know through every
Innovation cycle you know the internet
mobile phones whatever Amazon has been
Cloud you know Amazon's done great how
do you stay on top of the curve and he
goes because we don't look for Trends he
goes we ask ourselves the opposite
question instead of saying what's going
to change we say what's not going to
change so basically he's like good we're
customer obsessed that's the number one
value for them and he's like number two
we ask what's not going to change oh P
are people ever going to want less
selection no are they ever going to want
higher prices no are they ever going to
want slower delivery no Okay cool so now
we know that those are never the never
changing things so all we got to do is
how to figure out how to give them more
selection lower prices and faster
delivery that's what they care about
they're never going to not care about
those things they're always going to
care and all we got to do is just
continually find a way to do that so I
think that gives you a sort of long-term
orientation like for Hampton what would
you say say are the never going to
change things
I've got to figure that out frankly when
I started it was the same thing as
Zuckerberg which was I just want to like
be around smart people you know what I
mean are people ever going to want to be
around lower quality Founders no they're
always going to want that bar going up
that they would look in their peer group
and they're in awe how did I get in this
room right I think that's going to be
the first feeling you want to create is
holy [__] all the other people in my
group are awesome I can't wait to talk
to these people right that's going to be
I think always the number one the
quality of the other members in their
group to them and then I I think the the
thing I've been thinking about is
they're always going to want their peers
to be committed so you have if so we've
been thinking about what happens if you
don't show up to a meeting it's like
well we should just ban them let's ban
them you miss them both of those things
we mentioned hurts Revenue because if
you make the exactly you want to
increase Revenue widen the door baby let
them all in they'll let everybody who
wants to pay the bill come in okay but
now you've ruined the quality of member
problem you know the long-term people
will never want this to go in that
direction you're screwing that up for
short-term profit same same thing on the
people don't show up you ban them or you
also you know have to go ahead and
remove that subscription revenue from
from the from from the old stripe
account
and so you're not going to want to do
that either
but it will only happen if you take this
long-term orientation and say no no the
thing we value the most is people want a
product it's high quality people that
show up and care about this community
about this group and if either of those
two every decision has to be first and
foremost from that point of view does
this increase the quality of our members
or decrease it does this increase the
commitment levels or decrease it and I
also think that so you you were given
the example of Facebook and Amazon and I
looked at those as examples as well but
let's go outside of the tech world so uh
two brands that that I uh I'm looking at
that have lasted a long time Louis
Vuitton Louis Vuitton has lasted maybe
250 years now and when you think of
Louis Vuitton you know what you're
getting same at New York Times New York
Times has been around for 250 years not
Everyone likes them but you know what
they're pursuing which is their version
of the truth but then let's go to
Raising Cane's ever been to Raising
Canes love raising case I met the
founder of Raising Canes once he is
awesome you guys gotta I don't know his
name but Google Raising Cane's sound
founder and like watch talks with this
guy he's like a southern boy I think
from Louisiana he started a chicken
finger place I think at LSU and if you
go to Raising Kings now here's what
you're gonna get they all they sell is
chicken fingers you can basically get
them deep uh breaded and deep fried or
not breaded and deep fried and then I
think they only sell fried or fried or
obesity fried which one do you want yeah
like there's like there's only there's
no options and you get it on a styrofoam
like a styrofoam uh like uh school lunch
box like type of thing and they're not
fancy but you know what you're gonna get
every time and he's like adamant he's
like We Are Gonna perfect this we're
gonna get this it's gonna be fried the
exact same time every single time and
it's not sophisticated but you know what
you're gonna get another brand that I
like
[__] Dollar General you ever go to a
Dollar General yeah of course dude it's
it's not sophisticated it's not high-end
but you know they're just gonna have a
ton of stuff and it's going to be low
quality and it's going to be affordable
you know what you're gonna get every
time so I don't think you need this
sophisticated like it's day one here at
Amazon and we're like no you don't need
that you could have like no like we're
fashion Nova like it's cheap apparel
that you know you don't have to make a
lot of money and you could buy it and
we're always going to be on top of [__]
you don't need a lot of that stuff uh
that high-end like sophisticated stuff
you can be anything but it's just cool
that like to see people who are adamant
about what they are and they just
deliver value every time or at least
they're focus on the brand so anyway
that's my spiel about that and the
reason I was thinking about it was
because you were talking about
Outsourcing stuff and I'm like oh that
definitely seems cheaper but is it
cheaper for every role in the long term
because you have to build in order to
build a brand that lasts a long time
and let's let's let's be straight here
this is all about like doing dope [__]
it's also about making more money I
think you can make more money if you
drag out your Excel sheet you're like oh
this grows 30 20 every year yeah drag
that [__] out for 50 years AC let's see
what's going on over there right this is
it's this is also rooted in like
Adventure and fun exciting and in greed
so I don't want to get that twisted uh
but anyway you have people who want to
work for you for 10 20 years uh it gets
really interesting and I think you can
actually like embed different things in
culture do you know White Castle you
ever heard of White Castle you know what
that is right dude White Castle I
[__] love White Castle I went and
looked at their like LinkedIn I was
trying to figure out their executive
team like all of them have worked there
for like 30 years and they used to make
fun of them like oh man these [__]
suits I'm like no no no no they know who
their customers they know what they're
doing and you get the same [__] every
time and it works because there are
people have worked there for [__] 30
years and they like know what the
company's about so anyway that's my rant
rant over but it's something I'm
thinking about it it's something I'm
thinking about I'm glad we just
discussed says publicly I'm actually
gonna I was taking notes yeah yeah good
uh I think that's cool I I take the
exact opposite point of view for the
record
um I do not think about building things
that are gonna last 15 100 years I think
that's really hard and I think it's
unnecessary I want to be the thing that
lasts 50 or 100 years not uh an
individual brand necessarily well you
are the brand if that's the way I think
about it is this
um it depends on how you want your
career to go some people get really
excited about building something and
being a part of something and working on
something for 30 years
I get more excited about taking like
sort of seven year chapter arcs of my
life and be like cool I want to have
five you know I only get One Life to
Live
um I want to experience all the things I
want to ride all the rides and so I do a
you know I did a a tour of Duty and I I
lived in Australia and Indonesia and all
these other places that was fun that was
where the Great Adventure I moved to
Silicon Valley in the heart of San
Francisco and I tried to do the billion
dollar startup thing now I'm doing this
basically cash flowing business side of
things and podcasting creating content
I'm a content creator now that's
interesting uh that's fun in a new way
I'll shift at some point uh you know you
know seven years from now I'm not gonna
be a content creator anymore or I'm
gonna shift the content I'm gonna Create
TV shows or a stand-up comedy set or
something yeah but you do realize that's
all rooted I'm gonna like Jujitsu your
ass you realize this is all rooted in
the same [__] which is like your BR it
is a consistent brand and you are
changing the monetization I might not
even put my name on uh like my name is
not always going to be front and center
on everything when you're a content
creator it is but other times it's not
for me the more important thing is I'm
not I'm not gonna Bank on people
recognizing my brand in order to do
something I do want to accumulate enough
financial freedom and Runway so that I
can go pursue things that don't have to
make money right away and
um and so but but you know it's all
about what you the vision for you you
have for yourself so that's why I was
talking about Rob Dyrdek has this vision
for his house you have a vision for
Hampton what you're trying to create
this is long-term enduring thing I have
a vision for my my life or my career
that is Chapters and episodic and I want
to have that variety and new challenge
where I have to like go become
uncomfortable and try to get good at
something new and learn a different you
know sort of yeah go learn the dark arts
of a different area of different
different whole different industry and
go become a beginner again that's
something I get excited about more so
than
creating one thing that's going to last
a long time or I'm going to be a part of
for a long time is that a phrase we're
going to start using the dark arts I
mean that's patent is so yeah
saying that right now
um where do you want to go
um let's move on okay I got two quick
ideas for you in general I want to say
this by the way in this pod I think
we're going to make a shift in how we
create the content so right now every
episode is this mismatch of
breaking down a business talking about
Frameworks an idea business idea here or
there I think what we're going to start
to do is
segment them better or chunk them better
theme the episode's better so you know
what you're gonna get and we just go
really hard at one thing so we're gonna
do episodes where it's really hard on
just ideas business opportunities that
we see we're gonna go really hard on
certain topics like um
one-man businesses or you know
businesses that have very few people but
just crush it it's gonna be a lot harder
for us to do the prep for that but I
think it'll make for much better
episodes so uh we've been talking a bit
about that I think we should put it out
there that we want to we want to start
doing that but until then let's mismatch
a little bit I got an idea for you so
okay if you made a grid of customers
that are easy to acquire or hard to
acquire on one side and then customers
that are not that valuable and super
valuable on the on the other axes
um
one box that interests me there is hard
to acquire Super valuable and the reason
why is because those companies can
become very very defensible very very
valuable right your value as a company
or even as a person is just based on how
easy are you to replace you want to be
Irreplaceable Irreplaceable that's how
you can actually make more money in the
long term so what's on that in that
quadrant like uh like a [__] plain
manufacturer or something like that
something that sells to government
so you go get government contracts not
easy
hard might be hard to do might be boring
to do long-term expensive government
contracts it might take you years to get
to the point where you can get one but
when you get one
very valuable and very defensible and so
um I was thinking about this I was like
what because I invested in this um
drones company called valency a long
time ago I've invested maybe many years
ago I have no idea how they're doing I
was a small investor I don't even get
the updates but
um at the time they were doing pretty
well and they had a uh you know I was
like okay well this valuation's a little
bit Rich for where you're at but why is
it you know why do you think this is the
right valuation and it was like
but they're about to get this government
contract that's 100 million a year
contract one one customer will now
become worth more than all their
customers combined because and what's
the term length of that contract I think
it was like a there was a couple that
they were up for I think they were like
sort of three and five year deals
something like that so it's like okay
these are huge deals that you can get
and once you get one government contract
you're sort of de-risked and you've done
all the you know the clearance and all
that stuff you basically you have to get
your company to a spot where you could
get a government contract and once you
have one being able to get the next one
becomes more likely because you're sort
of in The Trusted vendor Circle
so I was like oh that's pretty valuable
I was just thinking about one the other
day you know with this whole covid
pandemic
somebody out there has got to be selling
some kind of pandemic modeling software
or detection software to every
government in every country of the world
and this is also have like a network
effect where as soon as you provide
you're the provider of this product to
uh one government it's actually
something that all governments would
then choose you for because you know the
more governments you get the more
compelling your case becomes and so I
wonder who's building kind of the talent
what palantir did for I think uh like
National Security type stuff
somebody's got to be doing for
biosecurity so who is creating the uh
pandemic monitoring detection modeling
awareness program
that you can then go sell to every
single government on Earth as an
indefinite ongoing contract hey these
things happen once every 100 years we
have the Spanish Flu we got coveted all
right I'm just gonna go I'll be your
provider because hey they're devastating
when they happen and I could I could be
this for you for the next hundred years
I think that's a a hundred year company
that uh is probably quite defensive and
quite valuable if you can do it
I'll talk to some of my friends who work
at Pelletier I'm like hey what'd you
guys do today and they're like oh just
like uh stopped a terrorist attack in
France how about you I wrote a blog post
you know what I mean like until five
tweet Tuesday today yeah my favorite
Tweets in my newsletter it's cool have
you ever looked at it it's like those uh
have you ever worked at those there's
all these like net worth calculators
where you're like where will I be in 50
years and you're like well if you were
to start in like 1884 uh this is where
you'd be if you were starting like 1995
this is where you'd be and you can like
see like well because that this 50 year
or this 30 years actually had slow
growth this uh 10 years had fast growth
and you could like see all the different
scenarios you're like so if we take the
average it's this but if this happens
this so you're kind of like talking
about like that but with like potential
illnesses who have you researched out
there uh I haven't researched any of
this but I'm sure it already exists
these sort of like uh you know like
because people have been worried about
these sort of like viral
things but obviously they were
insufficient right so like whatever
existed obviously sucked because we
didn't detect it we didn't have any plan
for it and we had no idea how fast this
thing was spreading like literally the
best pandemic model I saw was made as a
side project by Kevin Systrom the
founder of Instagram for fun on the side
where he's like oh look I can break down
by state they are not the viral
coefficient basically of this of this
virus uh based off of this public data
I'm getting about hospitals and
hospitalizations and um I can use that
to kind of show which states are
flattening the curve versus which states
are about to go exponential and you know
they should really consider doing
something and it's like somebody's got
to be doing this
this got to be the easiest sales pitch
of all time right now is kind of what I
guess what I really mean it's like if
you're sitting at MIT or one of these
places just be like wear a sign that
says I went to MIT and then go walk into
the government building open up the
fanciest like Matlab you know like model
you could find and be like
you need to pay for this and just see
what happens I think I feel like they
can get you can get pretty far right now
with this pitch of like hey we'll help
you with the we'll help you keep track
of these viruses
do you remember about two years ago you
and I were both interested in people who
are trying to detect fires uh forest
fires do you remember that yeah yeah we
did it we did this on the Pod right
there was probably like one or two like
kids like college kids fooling around
with it but then there was like I think
two different companies that raise money
I think from Founders from fund and
actually they were ex-palanteer guys I
forget the name of the company it's a
four-letter word it was like gel or I
forget what it was but they were I tried
to invest in them and they were like
they weren't having it because they were
uh getting big and they they didn't need
any money but
do you know what happened to those guys
uh felt maybe was it felt f-e-l-t
um I don't know the name of it that's
really hard to remember uh but no and I
also don't know what uh what came of it
but yeah there was I remember when the
California wildfires were happening I
felt like every three months there was
like a new fire and the entire like
State of California was like covered in
Smoke
um
yeah I remember when that I remember
when that was happening to find early
detection of wildfires was like a like a
startup idea that a bunch of people got
funded for
yeah it was really interesting what we
need to do what I'll do not this week
but next week because we have Jack on
next because I'm gonna actually do
research and see how these guys are
doing because it's very similar to what
you're talking about but what was your
uh what and what was your other thing
that you were looking at you have this
other thing the Celeb you're going to go
from selling to governments to selling
to Jessica Simpson yeah exactly
yeah not the same IQ so basically this
next idea is
so celebrities are having this like deep
fake crisis uh crisis and opportunity so
deep fakes are getting really really
good
and celebrities now have a crisis plus
opportunity so the crisis is
you've seen this fake Tom Cruise it's
deep fake Tom Cruise this guy's like
amazing it looks just like Tom Cruise
and it's like a video you know it's this
is getting really good you're not going
to be able to tell dude did you see did
you see the do you see the ones where
they put our podcast in Spanish yeah
those are awesome by the way we should
do that we should release our podcast
and everything they were amazing they
were so good I mean and I've heard of
these new scams where they'll take uh
people whose voice and video you get
access to and they call your parents I
mean like Hey Dad look I'm trapped I
need some money can you please send it
like just don't ask questions to send
the money it's wild it's wild and so I
think there's an opportunity here so I
think celebrities who get paid for their
name and face and you know oh I gotta go
fly to you know Arizona and shoot this
commercial for Gatorade right now and
it's gonna be three days but I'm gonna
get paid all this money blah blah that's
gonna change into Kindred would like to
use your your AI clone in their
commercial you cool with that yeah you
get to sit at home and collect the check
and it's like maybe it's 50 less you
know expensive for the brand maybe it's
the same cost for the brand I don't know
but uh celeb you don't have to do the
work anymore
that's going to be a big deal so the
more famous you get now you're not gonna
have to actually do the appearance thing
because you'll just send your your AI
it's not double to go do it
so that's an opportunity but there's
also a a risk there which is what if
somebody's just doing it without your
consent and so I think somebody's going
to need to create a sort of celebrity
deep fake licensing company
so it's a company that goes and says
look we're going to create the legal
entity
that's going to house your name and
likeness that other brands can come
interact with when they want access to
this and we're also going to do the
detection to find out is anybody doing
the unauthorized use of your name and
face somewhere
um and we will handle all the takedowns
for you so it's kind of like a
reputation.com but for this new deep
fake thing so you basically will go and
I think you'll you need to it's almost
like Angel list you need to create the
legal framework for how these work you
need to go sell this to every agency and
say hey
you should we've created one for you
know you have one of these for all of
your your clients on your roster
and when a brand comes to you use this
to issue the license that has the rights
and controls on it that has the digital
encrypted watermark on it
um that has the tracking on it and then
we will also fight anybody who is trying
to use it without paying you because
that's going to become an issue as well
um that's what I think is going to
happen I think somebody can build that
company right now I used to get all
these emails when I first started the
hustle because what we would do is we
eventually bought a Getty's license
which is like 50 Grand a year but before
that we would use I would just type in
whatever picture I wanted and then I'll
go to Google and click like allow for
commercial use and then I would like I
would use those pictures on our website
and then at once we got popular we would
get all these emails from these patent
trolls they're not patent trolls I mean
we were we were using someone else's
picture and they would say send us three
grand and we'll go away otherwise we're
suing you and I started looking into
them and basically what they did was
they just built this technology so they
could detect if someone's photo was
being used and they would automatically
like crawl they would use like who is
and find out who the webmaster was and
send you this email and I wonder like
how those folks turned out like what's
going like how some of these people
actually built those those things and if
they were profitable I imagine so like
there was one time I used someone's
picture it was like in the I think it
was like the it was like a thumbnail
picture it was the smallest picture and
I didn't even know we used it and I
think maybe someone at our company took
a screenshot of it and like tried to
alter it and then put it on our website
in the smallest way and they totally
caught it and within like a few hours we
had to send them like three thousand
dollars it's like [__] they got us I
wonder like what that looks like in the
world of AI when you are having a bunch
of these fake celebrity videos you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah exactly so I
think somebody's gonna need to uh to to
create the good version of that so one
option has become the troll uh the other
option is become the official sort of
like broker of of these of the usage of
these digital defects
um all right so that's my second one the
company by the way is called felt
f-e-l-t.com felt that was the it was uh
that's what we talked about remembering
you want to talk about how you flew Ben
out to convince him to move with you
yeah I think it's good actually because
remote work is you know obviously all
the rage and remote work is great in a
bunch of different ways but I'm of the
opinion which is uh remote is great when
you have things figured out and you need
people who are just operational to do
things anytime there's a lot of needs
figuring out or creativity or just your
brain trust I think works best in person
um
and so I told Ben the other day I was
like Ben I think we're on to something
with what we're doing uh business
partner Ben business partner Ben I was
like you know he lives in Austin right
now and I was like you gotta I was like
you gotta move out here and he's like oh
but like you know I live here now and
Life kid we have family in Texas
I was like yeah I know but like you we
both believe the following right
um every time we get together
magic happens
um this can be pretty big like what
we're doing can become pretty big and so
even like a 10 to 20 percent Improvement
on uh what we're doing is actually worth
maybe tens of millions of dollars so
it's like you know it could be worth it
to move
um and California's a great place too so
it's not like I'm saying you know let's
go to a rural Ohio or something and um
and so he was like okay why do we do
this so he moved out here for the month
so he got an Airbnb in The Burbs or San
Francisco and The Burbs where I'm at and
he's like I got an Airbnb
brought his wife kid came out here he's
just been living here for the month and
um and I also I offered him I was like
dude I'll pay you
dollars which bleep that out
um if you move and he was like and I but
I told him I go
but the number drops by 20 every quarter
that you don't move because I was like
this is not like a standing offer
forever it's a burning it's an exploding
offer I said you should take your time
you should think about it but you should
also know every quarter that you don't
move that number goes down dude he
should tell you you come you get your
ass to Texas yeah no he knows I'm not
going anywhere he knows I'm not going
anywhere that's not the that's not the
deal I actually lived in Texas for a
long time uh and you know the other
thing is like here
in California you know in San Francisco
there is kind of like for for example
for our rolling fund there's so many
companies so many other investors so
many people in the startup world like
you want to be
like proximity Is Power you want to be
near as many other people as you can
that are doing the same sorts of things
as you as you are
um to the extent that your lifestyle
will allow it and so uh so yeah we'll
see he told me I think I think I got
like a 10 to 20 chance well I'm coming
out I was I was with him a week or two
weeks before he went out there and I was
shocked when he told me that he thought
that there was maybe a 20 chance that he
could be convinced and by he I mean the
the levy entity uh the the household and
I was shocked that it was 20 is it still
20 percent
I don't know I think so but uh we also
work a lot when he's here so I'm sure
his wife's like dude this is terrible
like you work more now like oh man I
don't want to do this and so uh so that
might be working against us the other
thing though is uh the way we work is
kind of goofy like um I don't think most
people do this but you know for coding
they have pair programming
it's not that popular but some people do
it what pair programming is I I think
um
what's the name of that agency that was
in San Francisco that was like a really
popular Dev shop uh it was like it like
went public at one point you know you
know the name uh yeah yeah I don't
remember it but yeah they popularized it
at least I don't know if they invented
or popularized it but basically it's two
programmers working on one computer you
know right it's like the uh the
engineering two girls one cup basically
it's like you sit together
there's one keyboard and you would think
well okay you have half the efficiency
like only one guy's working only one
guy's coding but actually you get more
than double the efficiency because it
keeps you completely focused and you and
your partner are basically both talking
things through it figuring things out on
the Fly and literally me and Ben do that
when he comes out here to work we I'm
like all right put your laptop down like
just we buddy up side by side at this
desk
and we'll just work on the same thing at
the same time and like I can't just like
open Twitter and start messing around
over there what's happening what are you
doing can't you can't just say open new
tabs you know uh as you're figuring
something out one of the guys pointing
something out you just sort of really
stacking uh that's why I call like
stacking Focus it's like whatever my
level of focus is plus is a level of
focus on the same thing so that's been
good the other is the in between time so
already when we work remote we call each
other all the time
uh you know probably on the phone two
hours a day three hours a day maybe on
calls either with others or just
ourselves
but what's happening now is we'll work
on something for a bit that's kind of
like us being on a call together working
on something and then we're like all
right let's go get food and we'll just
hop on our bikes we'll go to this taco
shop we go get this we go to the same
taco shop every day we get the same same
meal every day we play waffle ball
afterwards hold the hands if we skip
home basically but while we're doing it
it's sort of like the best ideas are
coming out
uh in all the in-between time and that's
the time where normally if we'd be like
okay bye close Zoom or close Google
hangouts or whatever and then you know I
put on a podcast and he does something
else and you know it's the in-between
time where you get the serendipitous
ideas
um so it just kind of reminding me how
valuable it is to work in person so
here's
here's the issue that you have or I've
always had with you which is whenever
I'm around you whenever I am around you
both of us are high high-ish energy
people where
you're the type of person that eggs
people on and then I'll egg you back on
or I could see like and I'm not even
that bad at that but you do I'm sure
there's a lot of other people like Suli
where you guys just start egging each
other on and it's like wait a minute
we're totally off track here we should
just do the same thing over and over
again does this having him around just
distract you further because I can see
you guys just like you're sitting on two
like love seats and you're throwing a
football back and forth and you're like
why don't we do this yeah what if we did
this it's like well [__] it let's just
do it right now it's definitely a part
of it okay every single day that's like
that I crumple up a piece of paper I
throw it to him he throws it back and
we're playing catch talking about
[__] that like you know things we
could do
that are not like just the obvious
things but the beauty of it is as I've
gotten older and I've gotten wiser and
I've been doing this podcast two things
have happened one I hang around you and
you're very good at just
doing the thing every day whether it's
your workout or it's whatever I'm just
gonna do the thing and I don't want to
get distracted by everything I just want
to do the thing as I hang out with you
is how it helps there was also a guy who
came on the podcast long time ago
one of the earliest episodes
and he designed it's he's from Peak
design they make these like camera bags
so he started his company sad that was
two years ago yeah this was like one of
the first 15 episodes I think and um he
uh he so he makes these camera bags who
knew and they do like I don't know at
the time like 70 million a year in
Revenue off of camera bags and I was and
like clips for your DSLR camera I was
like what the hell is this that big of a
market and he had done it off of
Kickstarter and he kind of inspiring guy
and uh as I was talking to him I go so
what's your philosophy around business
he goes he goes everybody's got these
like plans they got these ideas blah
blah blah he goes I think
it's like life and business is just a
six inches in front of your face
he's like it's just this it just held up
his hand six inches before he goes I
just look at this and I just do
the six inches in front of my face
that's all I'm focused on and I just do
that every day
and that stuck with me and so we have
you can't see it but on the wall here
I wrote six inches in front of our face
on a giant like post uh like a giant
sticky pad thing these things are great
by the way you should buy these these uh
giant sticky pad things where you sort
of tear the paper it's like a huge
Post-It note that goes on your wall dude
at Monkey Inferno your old office you
are like that guy you always had white
boards and like pads that was your thing
you were always standing up like writing
yeah that was you you always said that
yeah whiteboard sesh real quick so so
yeah I have it here and it says the six
inches in front of our face and so the
first thing we do every day when he
comes over is we re-prioritize the six
inches in front of our face it's like
what are the small no-brainer
steps forward that will make this like
one percent better today and we the
first three hours of the day we don't do
anything else besides knock those out
and um I think theoretically we could
just do that for eight hours a day I
would get bored out of my mind also I
can kind of get eight hours of work done
in three hours of focus
when I put my mind to it and so that's
what we do first and then for the rest
of the day we think okay what what else
could LeapFrog something forward Beyond
those one percent obvious improvements
so we knock out anything anything we can
think of that's a one percent obvious
Improvement the six inches in front of
our face first and so that's how we've
been able to stay focused
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
dude you shared something on Twitter
about uh what's this football player's
name Russell Russell okong yeah oh my
God so I'm not a football I'm not a
sports guy at all so I didn't even know
who this person was and you shared this
thing this basically who is he he was he
was he good yeah he was awesome he was a
former lineman so linemen are you like
the biggest guys on the football field
so he's you know probably I don't know
300 pounds or something like that uh
he's like six five he's he's six five
310 pounds when he plays yeah and he was
like a star like he won he like won a
Super Bowl ring he was a pro bowlers
awesome awesome player um I remember I
think he was playing on the Seahawks for
a while that's that's kind of what I
remember him uh he's now on Twitter
there's a couple of these athletes like
and Dominican Sue
um Russell okung that are like they're
kind of like on Tech Twitter somehow
like and so Russell and you could DM him
and they'll and he's he's been replying
to my DMs yeah like Matthew dellavedova
invited me to an event the other day I
was like this is so cool that they've
crossed over and they've got their
athlete Camp they've also got kind of
business Tech uh interest and there they
like the by the way the best thing about
it is they come in so humble
um which is like they uh
they don't like they don't come in with
this like well you know who I am
personality like this Saturday so we do
I started this basketball pickup game
every Saturday for Founders and
investors out here in the East Bay and
we rent this gym and then we we all just
play pick up for like three hours and uh
Zaza pachulia came and he's uh he's a
former player on the Warriors and he oh
really he tweeted like oh yeah I'll uh
I'll play and I didn't invite him to the
first one because I thought he was
joking when he replied and then he
emailed me after the first was like bro
what happened I didn't get the
information no way I was like no way oh
[__] you actually were gonna show up and
so he came this week and it was [__]
awesome dude like not awesome at
basketball obviously he's also a
basketball compared to us but he um Zaza
is is it like a big Russian looking guy
or I don't know where he's from where is
he from I don't know Serbia or I think
he's from I think he's from Serbia I'm
not 100 he's just Google it Georgia
Georgia he's uh yeah he's like seven
foot uh and he's just he's a beast and
so now he works for the war yours he
does like their business side their
operating basketball operations and
investing uh for them and uh he's just
super personable super funny guy like
was totally humble and like you know did
he play yeah he played with us for three
hours it was once it was amazing
um I was talking so much trash to him
and he was just such a good sport about
it it was amazing so yeah I just I gotta
say I was so I've been so impressed with
the way that kind of like the athletes
I've seen that crossover into business
and Tech they like they do it with with
like I don't know so much finesse it's
really impressive wait what did you
learn about I love seeing pro athletes
in real life and just like seeing them
joke around or like behind the scenes
Instagram videos where they're like hey
watch this I bet you I can jump over
this thing they jump over this like huge
thing you're like oh my God these people
like we're not the same type of person
was there any athletic attributes that
he had or was he just totally chilling
well yeah for sure I mean if you see
Zaza play in the NBA Zaza was basically
like a screen center like his number one
skill was he could set a huge pick to
get Steph Curry a shot
but when he played against us right he's
Steph Curry he's just draining shots
from all over the court you he didn't
even take these shots in the NBA you
never saw him take these shots and he's
just and he made all of them fast break
pulling up from the three-point line and
he has I was like when's the last time
you played he's like 2019. I was like no
way he's like no no I've shot around
he's like you know I'm in the basketball
facility so I shoot around but he's like
I I don't even know last time I like
played it like I can't like it kind of
like a competitive game and uh so a
couple things so his warm-up was like a
real warm-up like he like he's talking
but he's doing these like hip flexor
openers and I'm like oh yeah he's like
he's just he's actually an athlete he's
had to like get his body ready many many
many times over and so you see like a
bunch of the dudes who come in and it's
like yo here's this VC or here's this
like Tech founder and we're like I don't
know I guess Tyler touched my toes is
that what I do to warm up like we don't
know we don't even know what to don't
even know what to do to warm up whereas
he's like doing these like uh you know
hip openers the second thing is when he
played obviously his game is a lot
better than you see on TV because
you know where the competition is so you
you gotta you gotta be a star in your
role in the NBA and he was a star in his
role as this like paint protector screen
Setter here he could do a lot of other
things that he never got to show there
uh the other thing is like he was like a
bear so he was mostly you know just
playing point guards passing the ball
mostly
um like getting everything obviously he
could post any of us up he's got a foot
on all of us you know in terms of height
so he wasn't just abusing that but when
it but like we beat him the first game
and then they won like six straight and
then you beat him you beat his team yeah
we won the first game yeah they were
just like you know whatever we got after
a quick start
um
but then the they went on a 6-0 run or
something like that just crushing
everybody and then when we came back out
to try to beat them as a very
competitive game and then it's like we
poked the bear it's like all of a sudden
he started driving to the hoop and he
started like playing like aggressive
it's like oh yeah don't forget the bear
can kill you uh the bear might be nice
right now but the bear will let you know
that like I could kill you if I wanted
to and he just chose which style he was
gonna yeah he's like let's let's just
put it to a six now we wear the three
let's just put it we'll just put it out
of six just for a few minutes don't get
it twisted this has been a three up till
now I'm just gonna show you that then
I'll go back down
wow that's awesome
um that I love seeing those types of
people like just like in normal settings
um and so um talk about Russell so what
Russell's doing I I saw him you shared
it he has his website and it's here's
why it's interesting one he's we'll put
this we'll see what he's doing he's
doing a 40-day water fast that alone is
interesting but what's even more
interesting is he's doing it in a very
like I wouldn't have expected this like
six foot five 300 pound football player
to be so introspective and if you go to
his website do you know the name of his
website actually no I will have it in
front of me if you just Google his name
and then go to his Twitter and you can
click off to the link he's got this
website hey it's built on ghost which is
like a pretty like in the know nerdy web
platform I think it's okungfast.com is
at least where the I think that's where
the
um
that's where you posted if you just
Google it you'll see it but it's like a
yellow website and like he has email
pop-up pop-ups and like everything is
set up really actually like exactly how
it should be like the email pop-up is
like thoughtful and then you go to a
confirmation page that's thoughtful and
he's blogging every single day and he's
posting the same picture every day so as
of now I think he started this thing at
260. I have to know I think we buried
the lead so he's he's gone he's going on
a 40-day water only fast he's lost a
hundred pounds so far doing it and
obviously it's not just about the weight
loss it's about like sort of like the
mental Challenge and the mental Clarity
that he's getting as he's
doing this like you know sort of this
this very uh it sounds to me like a
really intense fast I think he's on day
21. well he talks about how it's a
spiritual thing and he basically like he
he's just so much more thoughtful than I
ever would have picked this guy just
because I'm stereotyping like an NFL
player and like his writing is very good
and very clear and there's a lesson that
he's learning each day and he talks
about that and everything's well written
it's just wonderful it's a really really
cool fourth day was the hardest he goes
because this is where the body is
transitioning into a new state so he's
like I had headaches fatigue my body was
transitioning to using fat as the energy
source rather than you know the in the
input of new uh you know carbohydrates
and whatever
and he looks good so you could see even
when he started it you look at day one
where he started he still looked uh
pretty lean now you look at him at day
one he's starting to get like skinnier
and skinnier and skinnier and his
writing is starting to change it's very
fascinating and he's been tweeting about
it every day as he goes I need to
blogging about I think it's awesome I
love seeing this right uh yeah and he's
also like he's on day 21 he's on day 21.
he's also like a Bitcoin Max he's an
interesting guy by the way there's a a
guy I met named Byron Jones who retired
this year
um he was like one of the best
cornerbacks in the in the in the league
and he retired I think at 30. so he came
into the league probably 21-22 and he
retired at 30 which is an early
retirement and he got paid very well
probably made like I don't know 80
million dollars playing in the NFL but
he had said something when he retired
which is that I can't run or jump
anymore and which is shocking because
this is like one of the most athletic
guys
that was in the NFL at the time when he
was playing and I went to a dinner he
had a 44 inch ver wow 44 inch ver and
now he's just hit broad jump
um freak my buddy Romine uh hosts this
event called game time every year in LA
and it's basically a mix of investors
and athletes that get together and so
I've gone the last couple years and he
hosts this dinner and at the dinner
there was a few NFL players on the table
and they all mentioned like uh I forgot
what they were called a torbital not
torbital it's not the steroid it's like
some shot that NFL players get
basically it's a pain pain tolerance
shot a pain reduction shot painkiller
and they're they were just like dude
that shot
it's like magic and it's a curse they're
like because it doesn't make you feel
better right it just makes you not feel
pain no no you feel better but sorry it
doesn't cure an injury but it doesn't
cure the underlying issues it's like you
he's like we would go from you know
Sunday you play
uh Monday you feel bad
Tuesday you feel like man I was in a car
accident and their body feels like it
was in a car accident you're like
there's no way I'm gonna be able to
practice on Thursday and play next
Sunday like that's just like where my
body's at on Tuesday versus Sunday seems
crazy and they said that like uh they're
like man that you know like the culture
in the NFL is like you got to play
obviously and so these like a lot of
guys get get in the habit of taking this
one shot T something I forgot what it's
called and they take the shot and
they're like it's like a miracle dude
like within an hour you're running again
and they're like you went from not you
know like limping to like you're just
back to you
but also every time you do it it's like
taking time you know it shortens your
career because this is so bad for your
body what you're actually doing to your
body when you do that is you're not like
it's not like the underlying tissues
have healed in the process and um it's
kind of a crazy thing so I think one
cool thing about Russell's doing is he's
basically like trying to rewind the
clock on you know when you're in when
you're alignment they tell you to beef
up and what he's doing is is doing a
sort of a rapid and drastic change in
his physiology in order to get his
weight down so that he can live a little
you know longer healthier life as he
goes
yeah he said I went through a pulmonary
embolism I don't know what that is is
that a heart thing uh I had lacerated
lungs no idea how you get lacerated
lungs but that's wild a series
yeah a series of surgeries ligament and
ligament and tendon damage and getting
up every day was just really hard I
thought magically when I finished
playing it would get easier but it got
harder harder I had completely depleted
my testosterone so he basically just
explains he's like I was left in
shambles and so that's I guess one of
the reasons why he's done this and I
think it's really really really cool I
don't think I'm gonna do it shout out to
him I like I like seeing him do it what
else you got
um I like this question I got so a guy
tweeted at me I want to get your take on
it so his name's Christian vanufel uh
great name so Christian says question
for you Sean he goes what work seems
like small boy stuff but actually packs
a punch so we have this phrase we say on
the Pod all the time no small boy stuff
and we don't even like spend a ton of
time defining it because honestly it's
always stuff is kind of obvious but I
would say the general buckets of small
boy stuff would be
um you know overly worrying about things
um small boy stuff would be thinking
small rather than thinking big thinking
short term rather than thinking long
term
um you know caring too much about what
other people think of you you know
there's a whole bunch of things that you
classify as small boy stuff like
complaining when things get hard uh or
things don't go your way complaining in
general waiting in general these are all
like small boy moves
but
I thought his question was great because
the magic is in things that other people
think are small but actually pack a
punch and I had an answer but I'm
curious what your answer would be I'll
give you you want me to go first you
want to go first I'll give a very quick
example we had our I keep talking about
the offsite my CEO the company he put
all this effort into creating like
little individual awards for people and
like writing like uh appreciation notes
and like being very thoughtful in the
itinerary and I was like dude just like
who gives a [__] let's just get in the
room and hang out he put all this work
into it spent hours and hours and hours
100 worth it I I was giving him a hard
time and then afterwards I go nope you
were right I was wrong that that is an
example of things that seem below your
pay grade that you you proved it was
worth it love it uh I would actually
also give you credit because that would
be one of my answers which is
um admitting when you're wrong openly
and quickly I remember hearing a story
about
um one of the guys at Sequoia who's
awesome uh like helped build Sequoia
into like the most successful VC brand
or one of the most in a long time
somebody asked like what makes him great
they go all he cares about is getting it
right he'll be in a meeting with you
he'll say his opinion and somebody else
will say their opinion and you know most
people either start to debate or uh like
we're kind of like it's like we're
talking past each other it's like I'm
talking about one thing you're talking
about another and I'm the boss so I'm
gonna get my way and he's like he's the
first guy he has this phrase he always
says well he'll go
okay nope I like your way better let's
go with that
um like nope that's better like let's go
with that is a uh a awesome small but
big thing you could do as a leader in
any company it sets the culture that
it's not about who's right it's about
getting it right getting to write you
know over time
um here's what I wrote as some of my
answers I said
small things that seem like small boy
stuff is actually big doing customer
service yourself early on so being on
the front lines
um answering customer service emails uh
questions feedback picking up the phone
all that stuff
um manually onboarding your first 10 or
100 users so um
literally yourself sitting there with
them you know going to sit side by side
with them and having them install your
product or on board onto your product
and and answering their questions seems
like an unscalable small boy way of just
spending your time actually no it's a
huge huge thing and it'll teach you a
lot about your product and your Market
um sending follow-ups follow-ups
following up with somebody who didn't
answer you always feels like you know
like a little low status [__] move but
it packs a big punch follow-ups are
where all the magic is and I think
there's also a big piece of follow-ups
which is a lot of people don't follow up
because they don't hear back and they
assume
they say they're saying no they don't
like me they hate they hate this idea uh
you don't want to look stupid they get
in their head about it they start
assuming the worst instead assume the
obvious people are busy and they forget
uh people are busy and didn't get around
to it yet
um and when you follow up with that
mindset that's the sort of no small boy
mindset it's like I'm offering something
of value to this person of course they
would want it maybe they haven't yet
seeing the value in it maybe I didn't
convey properly or they just haven't
gotten around to it they're busy and
that's okay um I'm still here
um the other one I wrote was finding
things that recurred daily and making
them two percent better because daily
things that you do things you do with
high frequency compound
um if you made them slightly better and
so this is where I think a lot of people
are like why are you optimizing for your
shoes or your mattress or your pillow or
whatever like why are you why do you
care so much about how you're uh you
know like I'm a stickler for how a
meeting starts I'm always like no no at
the start of every meeting we say all
right the purpose of this meeting is
this and a good outcome of this meeting
would be you know why and um if you
can't say X and Y like we're not doing
the meeting I'll stop people and I'll
say no no do this or uh when people talk
I'll be like hey you know you're talking
a really low voice and you're not
sitting up straight like can you just do
it like say it with some energy it'll
make a difference and like but that's
every meeting then people know that's
how we do meetings and so once you teach
me how we do meetings we're gonna have a
lot of meetings at this company so we're
gonna make them better we're not just
gonna have shitty meetings let them let
them slide so finding recurring things
and making them slightly better because
it'll compound over time so that was
mine
what was your partner's name at Monkey
Inferno um
furcon uh furcon I think was like I
don't know him well but I could only I
could hang out with him for 30 seconds
and I could just tell he's the man at
seeing redundancies or not redundancies
uh seeing things that you do over and
over and over again and be like yeah
we're gonna get rid of that and we're
gonna fix it by doing this this and this
and it seems like you're like dude
you're just slowing us down what are you
doing he's like no no you got to go fast
to go slow or you got to go slow to go
fast he seems like that type of
Personality did he do that all the time
he was definitely
um he had you know the Hacker's laziness
which was like
I'm not gonna do something unless I'm
unless it's clear that it's gonna that
it matters like I'm just gonna do [__]
just to do [__] that's the first thing
um second thing I'm not gonna do the
same thing every day if I if I'm doing
it if I have to do it multiple times I'm
automating this and same thing he would
look around and be like
yo what's Sean do what's Jason doing
like are the non-technical people and
he'd be like
hey Neil you see Jason keeps what he's
doing is he's going and finding each
person manually on Twitter you should
just scrape this whole list put it in a
database and and copy paste this code
snippet so that he could put that on his
machine so that he could just have his
leads ready so he can go faster he would
do a lot of stuff like that like he told
a story early at Apples App 11 was a
mobile ad tech company that um is now
worth billions of dollars he was the
co-founder of it and what for Khan told
me a story he's like yeah Adam
the CEO he's like one thing he really
cared about was his dashboard like what
does our dashboard look like so that I
have visibility and he's like he's like
I kind of watched Adam to see like is
there really any value out of this or is
he just you know sometimes CEOs just
have pet projects they just want to look
nice and he's like is it that or is
there value here so he shattered him
he's like all right I'm not going to sit
on my computer instead of your computer
you show me what are you looking at with
this dashboard what do you do with it
and so he showed him and he's like yeah
I do I look at this I look at this and
that tells me who we need to go after
um for these deals and I need to figure
out how much to offer them so that I can
get them faster like you know instead of
just saying you should work with us for
these features if I just make a monetary
offer that's better than their current
ad Network they'll switch and he's like
okay so you need to figure out this list
you need this data and then you need to
know
a projection of how much we can make
with them so you can offer less than
that but still more than what they're
probably making for their current ad
Network and I should show you which what
the current ad network is
in this dashboard I'll just figure that
out by looking at their SDK blah blah
blah hey look he basically put together
this like
command center for the CEO and he's like
he basically built a sales tool rather
than working on features of the product
he's like I'm gonna build you something
and so what they did was they would go
to a developer they say you should use
our ad Network and they're like I
already have an ad Network he said cool
I'm guessing your ad Network pays you
nine dollar CPM and they're like yeah
something like that he said cool we'll
pay you 22 dollars
is it how can you do that uh don't worry
there are ad networks better I consider
the convention right networks better but
I'll just sign this paper that says
we're already going to pay you 20 no
matter what like I'm just confident it's
going to perform because I know our ad
networks better and they're like okay
he's like but here's you know you got to
switch and we have these two Engineers
standing here next to me they're gonna
help you switch today and then they
would just and they just rolled through
the ad Market because they were able to
go to people and make them no-brainer
offers how did they make them no-brainer
offers they because they had this
Command Center internally that was
how big is this app what are they
currently using how much are they
currently making how much do we think we
can make off them and then how do we
have a a spread there that we can work
with and so I thought that that was a
great example of for con uh figuring out
how to make the company successful in a
way that most Engineers would not do
because most Engineers just want to work
on product and not even product like the
under the hood parts of the product
which is like even worse than making the
product better
dude this is the most wholesome episode
we've done in like two months
talking about like CEOs fighting each
other and [__] no one's making no one's
getting made fun of we're totally
aligned lots of take-home value here
this is this is a uh this is like the
most wholesome thing we've done in a
long time I actually am like I feel like
I'm learning this is this episode was
good because I'm sitting here in a
notebook taking notes I'm learning
that's a good some learning yeah I love
that well that's it that's the episode
good pod
[Music]
foreign